[Applause]
all right here with analysis of all this
in Joe Biden's latest election Wes
former Speaker of the House new ging Mr
Speaker your reaction to all the news
tonight the Biden's Joe Biden pressuring
Israel to put a pause on the War uh you
hear about these 10 family members tens
of millions of dollars from some of our
top geopolitical foes uh Joe Biden now
losing according to the New York Times
in five out of six swing States but in
denial about it your reaction all of
it well I mean first of all chairman
James comr is doing a great job and
people need to realize he's doing that
job under enormous pressure from the
administration and from the left so I
really commend what he's doing uh second
I have to tell you as I listened to him
describe the $30 million I was reminded
of the scene in The Pink Panther where
Peter sers as a detective is on the
stand and the prosecutor says on your
salary how could your wife buy all of
these these things and he says well she
was really good with the kitchen budget
uh what you have here is so clearly
visibly a bunch of people who are Crooks
I mean this isn't a complicated case Joe
Biden and his family are collectively
The Sopranos of New Jersey I mean of
Delaware uh they're clearly Crooks and
you have to start with that the manye
you say to yourself could this be an
episode of The Sopranos it all falls
into place so that's the part of it the
other part here which I think is
frightening is is Andy McCarthy who's a
very serious former Federal prosecutor
uh wrote recently we're going to have to
come to grips with the fact that we have
a Chinese Communist agent in the White
House the president now I think I don't
know agents too strong a word you
clearly have in Joe Biden a person who
by any reasonable standard was corrupted
by a series of our enemies Uh Russian
money Kazakhstan the original corruption
in Ukraine uh the Romania and of course
the Chinese Communist and when you be I
think and I've talked to Chairman comr
before and to Chairman Jordan and others
chairman Smith I mean they are gradually
going to paint a picture so
vivid that every American's going to
understand what whether you're for the
left you're for the right if you're an
American Patriot you're going to
understand you have a president who is
fatally corrupted and who was corrupted
by our deepest enemies in the world he
he swore as president he swore as a
candidate that never once did he ever
speak to his son his brother or anybody
for that matter about these foreign
business deals but yet uh Hunter's
partner Deon Archer identified over 20
meetings he was was calling into we know
5 days before he leveraged a billion
dollars to get the prosecutor in Ukraine
fired to allow his son with no
experience addicted to drugs at the time
uh to to continue to get paid uh we know
he was on the call with Baris Executives
we know he met that Russian oligarch
that James comr talked about at Cafe
Milano the level of just pure lying and
the sheer amount of money for from just
oil in China and and Ukraine is
breathtaking from ay kid that admits he
had no experience at all whatsoever I'd
love that gig kind of if you give it to
me so at everyone in the
audience well first of all you may
remember Sean a few years ago we had a
terrorist picked up who had parked a
bomb in Times Square which luckily did
not go off uh he was brought in front of
federal judge the federal judge said to
him two years ago you became a US
citizen you swore loyalty to the United
States how do you explain this and the
terrorist looked him in the eye and said
you know judge I lied I'm a terrorist I
lie uh what you have is go back to The
Sopranos you wake up in the morning as a
crook you have two Futures you can tell
the truth and go to jail or you can keep
lying every morning for apparently years
Jo Biden has woken up and said you know
I think I'll just keep lying and so far
it's worked former Speaker of the House
new kingri thank you sir